well our next guest this is a good one
Brian Cranston is one of Hollywood's
most beloved actors known to many for
his emmy-winning role in Breaking Bad
now Cranston is starring in a second
season of the popular drama series your
honor as ex-judge Michael desiato it
airs on Showtime with Showtime rather
which like CBS is a division of
Paramount Global and in this clip we see
cranston's character take the stand to
recall the night his son was
accidentally killed take a look
bullet hit Adam in the neck
I looked past him and I saw someone
standing next to the kitchen in the back
and
he was holding a gun in his hand
Adam fell to the floor
I ran inside and I I yelled for help
I held my son in my arms as he died
so real Brian Cranston good morning good
morning how are you oh we're great well
you're you're in one of my favorite
cities New Orleans oh yeah this is the
first series you've done since breaking
bad what is so appealing about this
character and what you've been able to
do with it for the last week that really
got me was the the conceit of the first
season which was what would you do to
save the life of your child right and
any parent I know said I would do
anything and then the follow-up question
is would you knowingly become a criminal
if you really thought it would save your
child's life and the answer again is yes
but then that's what my character does
he makes this quick impulsive decision
save his son's life and then he gets
into this downward spiral of telling a
lie backing that up with another lie and
pretty soon he's a liar and nothing he
did actually saved his son and
incriminating and innocent person I know
see that's the thing yeah that's a Twist
now this series was supposedly supposed
to end after season one
yes were their thoughts to it ending
after season one there was um there were
some ideas to be able to go into a
season two and after the tragic ending
of season one I thought well if you
really want to do this and Showtime back
the idea of exploring grief and despair
and also uh the the the possibility of
redemption yeah and the power of apology
of course uh not only asking for
forgiveness but also granting it yeah I
mean that's it's it's actually a human
strength in character uh Brian since
we're talking about Redemption apology
grief tragedy I mean one I mean one
aspect of your biography which I did not
know uh is that your own father walks
out at 11. you're 11 years old uh and
your mother she's got a drinking problem
and you end up being raised by your
grandparents that's a that's a pretty
formative experience thanks for bringing
yeah
[Laughter]
I did not know um
and I'm just you know I'm curious how
that has shaped your ability to step
into difficult roles like the one you're
in that's a good question Tony
you know everyone's journey is is their
own unique experience and uh I wouldn't
wish that upon anybody you you want
Harmony and and and togetherness in a
family and that's certainly what I want
to bring to my family now as my wife and
I have been together for 36 years and
it's like it's I want that stability
yeah
um but my experience was my experience
and so I have to just go along I think
it does though give you opportunities to
say oh when was I filled with despair
when was I nervous or filled with doubt
or as references references and that's
what an actor has to do you have to be
willing and able to open up the treasure
chest of your own experience and your
own emotional
um you know value and and pull out the
the things that you may not be wanting
to show people you know greed and and
and jealousy and resentment and all the
things that we humans feel and pull it
out be so Breaking Bad into what a
decade ago has it been that long yeah it
is looking back is there anything you
would have done differently with that
series
ask for more money
you've changed that was pretty
successful yeah it was successful but
I'm so serious no first of all it's
written by uh Vince Gilligan and his
staff that is so genius and they they
knew exactly what to do and how to do it
and actors step in when the writing is
great uh it's much easier for us in fact
the hardest work that an actor has ever
had to do is on poorly written material
because you're trying to find some
measure of honesty in it and it's not
well constructed and you struggle but
when it's really well done it's it's
like you know yeah but are you by
implication acknowledging that a time or
two in your career you have worked with
poorly written material yes
when you first start out the answer is
yes yeah right I mean you got to work
with what you got you got to work with
what you got you don't know what you're
you have you just say yes because you
need that experience you want to you
have to pay your rent and bills and
things like that like anybody else I
have to say this before you go um I saw
you not leaving good stick around please
we'll be here until nine
um you know we were talking during the
Super Bowl you game won our Super Bowl
pregame show and I'm joking around with
you and Aaron about dos Hombres which is
the best mascara on the market yeah at
home in my freezer you know and I'm just
joking around with them like hey man
send me a bottle you know I asked for
everything anytime we have a guest on
the show
sure enough a week later a box pops up
so I just want to say thank you I
appreciate you for sending me a bottle
of the best my pleasure yeah dos Hombres
is uh going we're now the number four
Mezcal wow three and a half years yeah
so we're excited oh wow that's great
yeah well you know I have a book to
share with you so enjoy
streaming series it could be a major
theater release uh yeah play I mean
there's a lot of options you know what
you were saying about your experiences
yeah there it is right there it's Pub
day today how about this apples wow how
about that Brian Cranston
go out and get it today oh wow
the season finale of your honor
we'll debut this Friday on Showtime
streaming and On Demand here it is